[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
people are being left to die on the
pavement outside one of india's biggest
hospitals as doctors struggle to cope
with the latest surge in coronavirus
sky news has witnessed the chaos inside
one of the country's leading hospitals
and the desperation outside as people
wait for treatment
the number of coveted cases in india is
now doubling every 10 days with the
country reporting the highest daily
cases ever recorded in the world
for two days in a row deaths have
increased
75 percent in the last week in the uk
more than half of all adults have
received their first dose of a covid19
vaccine
but in india the number of daily doses
being administered has declined in
recent weeks
there's been a sharp increase in
hospital admissions
with 544 beds occupied in delhi in
mid-march
compared to the latest figure of more
than 18
000. our special correspondent alex
crawford visited one hospital in new
delhi
a warning that from the start her report
includes pictures of people
desperately ill with covid and also
distressing images of some
who died before they could be treated
the emergency room of one of delhi's
biggest hospitals
they're constantly having to move out
the dead to make way for more
and most of those in this room are dying
and they haven't been admitted yet to
the hospital
the doctors are simply overwhelmed
scrambling for oxygen
and reduced to begging for help on
social media
india set a worldwide record nobody
wants for a second day running it topped
the number of
global daily coronavirus cases
they're shocked and ashamed at how the
country's healthcare system is all but
breaking
the weak and ill have spilled out onto
the pavement outside
and there's no dignity and death here
the final few breaths taken by this man
came after his brother had begged for
oxygen for him for six
hours some turned up barely
able to walk only to turn around
immediately
after being told they'd be better off
trying elsewhere
whilst this family brought their mother
but saw her die minutes after reaching
what they hoped was help
this hospital is useless she's shouting
but it's not isolated in its inability
to cope right now
only grief is here in abundance
distraught relatives found no beds
little oxygen
few staff and even less hope i have a
message for the government please do
something
and please release some oxygen supply
people need it here people need beds
here people need meds here
people need walls here people need
injections
people need medicines and there are deep
worries that the figures could be
even more alarmingly high with so many
deaths
unreported or unlocked the numbers of
people who appear to be
very ill indeed continues to build
outside this hospital
and still none of them being admitted
which seems to indicate that if this is
happening to one of the biggest
hospitals in the capital what on earth
is happening
outside of the capital and almost
certainly there are more added to these
grim statistics
with every single hour yesterday we came
here with our father
just here but no one came to see him
he's just
shouting that to see me see him in no
one came he died
no one's seen him either all they can do
is wait and plead
if he's taken in and that's not
guaranteed he'll be immersed into this
one man told us there were just seven
oxygen cylinders
for 70 people india is now home to the
world's
fastest growing coronavirus crisis with
fears that the virus mutations
could be resistant to the vaccines they
seem
unable to control it and utterly
unprepared to deal with it
alex crawford sky news delhi
well dr gurjar babu is a professor and
epidemiologist at the public health
foundation of india and joins me now
good morning to you
um can you explain the extent of
the crisis that india is experiencing
now
good morning the situation is really
concerning
this health system especially in some of
the states where
it's not really strong for a very long
time is taking a major hit
even in the states where the preparation
for the surge was
reasonable they are not able to handle
the search because
the surge is at least five times more
where the preparations were nearly for
two times even in the best prepared
times
so in terms of mortality right now the
proportion of
deaths is reasonably low but
the absolute number of deaths are high
because more number of people are
getting infected
already there is insufficient supply of
oxygen
and also there is shortage of medicines
as a result of
all this the situation is grim and most
of the doctors and healthcare workers
are struggling to meet the surgery
and what is the reason behind the surge
or the reasons is one of them
predominantly this new variant that that
you're seeing
yeah it may be more than one variant
because
uh at least there has been some research
also from the uk regarding the double
mutant found in
india but there's also another triple
mutant found in the state of west bengal
and there might be more local variants
uh simply we do not have the data as of
now
to know how many variants are causing
this
this is also sort of facilitated by
congregations whether it is religious or
political
plus sort of letting off the guard after
a lower number of cases for a few months
so the combination of these factors have
resulted in major search
uh might the the real situation be uh
more desperate than it at first presents
we were just showing pictures from our
reporters um uh the report put together
by alex crawford correspondent in delhi
um and we've seen pictures of people
being
left on the floor reception in the
hospital
and dying where they where they lay this
is in delhi major city
what's the situation do we know across
the rest of
india in in the the villages
uh in my own assessment when i'm
observing
the pattern of the disease the southern
states
have relatively better uh health system
and they have been able to
to an extent manage the search but even
there there is
insufficient bets because the
really large number of cases but in the
northern india
it is really bad especially in uttar
pradesh and bihar
where the health systems are really poor
delhi mumbai
bangalore belong to a better health
system
in terms of infrastructure uh capacity
of the human resources
and yet uh we are finding uh problems in
these metros
uh in the areas of uttar pradesh and
bihar
and other rural areas the situation is
even more concerning
compared to the metros in your
estimation dr babu is this going to get
worse
uh i mean uh based
as an epidemiologist i can't say that
this is the peak of the second
wave i've been looking at several models
we might be
reaching the peak for the second wave
maybe in the second or third week of may
after that there might be a reduction in
number of cases
but that's too far away in terms of the
number of cases
and the health system capacity unless we
do
at least city level or district level
lockdowns to reduce the speed of
transmission
and also expand the capacity of the beds
by actually taking over some of the
private hospitals or medical colleges
uh by doing both of these will be able
to contain the search otherwise
uh it can be devastating uh you
mentioned there the lockdowns i know
that a week-long lockdown was imposed
but is that enough do you think that
there should be longer
uh stricter lockdowns yeah so
we had some bitter experience from
nationwide lockdown last time that's why
states are reluctant to impose lockdowns
but
i think it's absolutely necessary to
impose at least city level
or even statewide lockdowns for at least
14 days to begin with
to reduce the speed of transmission
beyond that
i think we'll have to measure in terms
of what number of cases are and
what kind of bed capacity we have and
how do we titrate the cases so that the
health system can manage the load
at the same time we should also be
looking at expanding the bed capacity
and redistributing the resources to
areas which need most
what happens in india will have major
implications for the rest of the world
because
if high circulation goes on it can also
lead to
a higher chances of getting newer
variants
and this is true for anywhere in the
world any place which has high
circulation
can lead to newer variants that's why we
need to have global collaboration
rather than probably singling out only a
few places which have higher
transmission
dr babu thank you very much for speaking
to us this morning
also this morning the prime minister has
been accused of proposing an unethical
and possibly illegal plan to fund the
refurbishment of his downing street flat
that was the allegation leveled at boris
johnson by his former advisor dominic
cummings
in a blog published last night he said
mr johnson's conduct fell
far below the standards of integrity the
country deserves
a warning that this report from our
deputy political editor sam coats does
contain some flash photography
can you get an election by the end of
this week elections
referendums these two men walked instead
for years through the biggest hurdles of
the modern
political era
so many times boris johnson came through
because of
one advisor permanently in the
background
all the way throughout his first 18
months in number 10.
but the strains and grudges that also
ferment behind this very door
can have consequences years after
as dominic cummings showed naming
leakers suggesting interference with
internal investigations
and most toxic of all accusations about
the costs of the refurbishment of this
flat
above number 11 that boris johnson and
his fiancee
live in in a 1 000 word blog dominic
cummings suggested that the prime
minister had been exploring ways of
getting
others to secretly pay for the lavish
makeover
a move which would break electoral law
he said i told him the prime minister i
thought his plans to have donors
secretly pay for the renovation were
unethical
foolish possibly illegal and almost
certainly broke the rules on proper
disclosure of political donations
if conducted in the way he intended at
his side through the toughest of times
he now claims he watched in horror
as the pm toyed with abandoning a leak
inquiry over lockdown rules
when it pointed to a friend of his
fiancee
i told him that he could not possibly
cancel an inquiry about a leak that
affected millions of people
just because it might implicate his
girlfriend's friends
he went on to say it is sad to see the
pm and his office fall
so far below the standards of competence
and integrity
the country deserves they're calling it
a nuclear dom the man boris johnson
brought in to help him run government
launching total war against his former
employer
but the allegation that matters is that
the prime minister
wanted to bend and break
the rules and the law that's the thing
that downing street are going to spend
days having to explain away out on the
campaign trail the prime minister's team
claimed he hadn't broken the law
interfered in a leak inquiry and always
acted properly
but in order to be able to kick
allegations about the flat into touch
they revealed he personally has now paid
the redecoration
himself at a likely cost of 60 000
pounds
but the man himself did not want to
answer about any of it
be it on how much he had to pay for the
flat or where the money came from
all that will be declared in the normal
way and uh
and i'm much more interested in telling
you about the regeneration
that we're hoping to see uh here or
we're already seeing
in t side cheers this man and his team
are hoping to make sleaze the
centerpiece of their election campaign
the allegations that dominic cummings
has leveled are very serious
and need to be investigated but look
this is just the latest in
a long line of accusations of
sleaze corruption grubby dealings
dodgy access he fights hard and he
fights dirty
not everyone in the tory party will
welcome that the prime minister has
triggered this row
so close to an election sam coats sky
news
in other news this morning rescuers
searching for a missing submarine in
indonesia say the vessel may have run
out of air
53 crew were on board when the sub
disappeared off the coast of bali on
wednesday
a woman who lost her job after
expressing views that someone's sex
can't be changed and transgender women
are not women
has told sky news she doesn't regret
anything she's done or said
maya forsata's opinion on transgender
people were deemed incompatible with
human dignity by a judge in 2019.
next week she'll repeal the ruling in a
case which could set a new
legal precedent our correspondent helen
ann smith reports
this is maya forsteater a tax expert a
feminist
and the protagonist in a bitter legal
battle about
sex gender and freedom of speech but
it's about having institutions that are
able to stand up she believes the body
someone is born with determines their
sex
and that this sex cannot be changed but
it's a belief that puts her at odds with
the rights of transgender people
at odds with the view that gender or how
someone identifies is more important
it's a belief that cost her her job and
a belief she's fighting to have legally
protected
it's the ability to talk about material
reality
the reality is there are two sexes
but sex matters and sex matters for
health care
sex matters for other people's privacy
it matters for how we understand the
world
and imagine organizations
but to some this view is deeply
transphobic
her contract at the think tank where she
worked was not renewed after colleagues
complained about tweets expressing it
she went to employment tribunal to argue
such beliefs should
have legal protection but she lost
the judge describing them as
incompatible with human dignity
and not worthy of respect in a
democratic society
her appeal is being heard next week if
i lose and this is not a protected
belief
then it's open season for
women in particular but for anybody who
speaks up about women's sex based rights
employers have to be able to think these
things through the judgment was
it was pretty resounding against you do
you accept that some of the things you
said
amounted to harassment in the eyes of
some and that that's what matters it's
how people perceive these things
no not at all there was nothing that i
did
that harassed anybody so if the belief
is protected that doesn't mean that
doesn't give you the ability to harass
or abuse anybody
her case has been extremely high profile
support from author j.k rowling made it
international news
but it's caused hurt and distress many
transgender people say her views amount
to a denial of their existence
and threaten a respectful workplace if a
person
obtains a gender recognition certificate
they should have the full
protection of of the law if we undermine
that then that
fundamentally under undermines
protections for all
trans people in the uk um trans people
in this country
are being vilified for something that's
a
natural hormonal development of the
brain
in the womb whichever side prevails in
this appeal it will set an important
precedent that will have implications
beyond just the workplace it will
determine how you can be treated simply
for holding these beliefs
even if they're never acted upon either
side could take the case to the court of
appeal if they lose
the stakes are as high as the issue is
divisive
helen and smith sky news
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's been a dry and chilly april so far
it looks as though we'll
keep the chilly theme in fact next week
does look quite cold but there will be a
little bit of rain to come monday
tuesday we'll see some pushing southward
so a little bit on the horizon but for
this weekend we're dominated by high
pressure
uh the high established to the north of
us with quite cool winds coming in
across more eastern and southern areas
in fact quite gusty winds
for southwestern parts today
temperatures picking up nicely though
and after a little bit of a nippy start
out there getting up to
maybe 20 celsius in some western fringes
of say north west wales but
inland around the mid to high teens and
northeastern parts where there's more
cloud around today
we'll be cooler at 11 celsius there'll
be a touch of frost tonight once again
under clearer skies
and then tomorrow some fair weather
cloud bubbling up through
sunday but otherwise pretty decent again
warmest in the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back a norwegian climber is
recovering
after he became the first person to test
positive for covid at mount everest base
camp
he was airlifted off the mountain along
with a sherpa and taken to kathmandu for
treatment
everest had been closed for nearly two
years because of the pandemic
milana vaselinovich reports
the pandemic has reached the world's
tallest mountain after a norwegian
climber and his sherpa tested positive
for coronavirus
mount everest has only reopened to
tourists last month
but some experienced climbers say the
outbreak was inevitable
everyone was aware that this could
happen this season we are running
expedition
during a pandemic here so it of course
we were aware that this could happen
uh we didn't think it would happen that
fast
travelers to nepal need to get a covet
test before departure
but there's no requirement for another
one before reaching base camp
so some climbers could be carrying the
virus and that
according to the man who scaled all of
the world's highest peaks
could be fatal but when you're at that
extreme altitude and you're already
suffering from
acute mountain sickness you know and
your lungs are already affected you're
having trouble breathing
i wouldn't have thought you'd have the
energy or the power to get yourself back
down and
uh very difficult to carry someone down
that's unconscious you need eight people
to carry a stretcher and obviously
there's vertical bits on everest it's
not just a walk
the outbreak has dealt a blow to the
nepalese government's decision to allow
climbing again
despite a rise in cases in the country
and an out of control
outbreak in neighboring india but nepal
relies on income from foreign climbers
and the pandemic had already wiped out
last season
if everyone would try to make it
to to run the expedition reliable
responsible
trying to keep everything safe to follow
protocols i think it should be possible
to run it in in a
responsible way milano vassilinovic
sky news
now there's a lot of excitement for
british gymnastics this year and that
jackie is back to tell us
more a lot of excitement in the studio
just right here
at gymnastics i know because you're a
gymnast what was your event again you
did
doesn't matter anything to get
gymnastics into the bulletin uh yes
young british gymnast jessica gadarova
took bronze in the all-round competition
at the european gymnastics championships
yesterday
while emily morgan came in fourth
britain's most decorated female gymnast
beth tweddle says the brits have the
talent to come away with multiple medals
in tokyo and at next year's world
gymnastics championships
which will take place in a city very
close to her heart
liverpool it's amazing to have the world
championships in liverpool i mean to
compete at a world championships
is amazing but to actually have it on
home soil
i i know the impact of having an event
in the uk i remember competing at the
2009 world championships and
i crashed out on bars but i remember
hitting the floor and
just the crowd went crazy to say don't
worry
get back up you can finish it and that
kind of really lifted my spirits and
then
a week later i turned everything on its
head and became world champion
so beth olympia is around the corner
european championships of gymnastics
taking place
this week what name should we look out
for who could win a medal for britain
in tokyo there's so many names to look
for the depth of the british team at the
minute is amazing double olympic
champion max whitlock
world champion joe fraser gianni's come
back after a couple of years of injury
on the women's side you've got the
downey sisters and you've also got the
gadarova twins they are
coming through on the senior ranks and
i'm excited to see their journey
well like the europeans it looks like
you know the russians are you know
the kingpins um at the europeans but
is it still simone biles and the
americans who everybody will be chasing
at the olympics i think everyone is
going to have all eyes on simone biles
she
is an incredible athlete the the medal
tally that she's already got going into
this championships
and she's only going to build on that
very tough sport gymnastics
probably you know you could argue the
toughest sport
what did you think when so many gymnasts
complained
to the white review about abuse about
bullying you know this is your sport
what were your feelings obviously it's
hard to hear and but for me
it is we want every child to be safe
regardless
of the sport and i just urge anyone to
come forward i had a really positive
experience and i just
urge people to come forward the white
review is
ongoing another seat and we'll look
forward to the report on that
how excited are you i know it's a very
different year but to be in olympic year
finally
it is the pinnacle of gymnastics it's
been a really tough year for everyone
and to have an olympic games to look
forward to this summer
is is amazing gymnastics gets i think
every four years
everyone raves about watching the
gymnastics and we see
that reflected in the participation
levels lots of gymnasts
wanting to sign up having watched the
olympics watch their heroes so
and this summer's going to be amazing
and i can't wait to watch it
do you miss it do you miss that high
level competition that feeling of going
out there
you're always going to miss that
competitive atmosphere and
like i said before walking into an arena
feeling that buzz feeling
people shouting your name the flags the
banners with all the
children have made and you're always
going to miss that but
do you know what gymnastics has been a
huge part of my life i'm never gonna
walk away from it
and the fact that i'm able to kind of be
on the other side of the fence now doing
the media i just
i just love it
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
there's some rain in the forecast coming
south on monday and tuesday it's been
such
a dry month so uh gardens and parks
really crying for some rain but uh this
weekend is dry because we've got high
pressure in charge
around the area of high pressure there
quite a brisk wind coming in noticeable
today across the southwest and a bit
more of a breeze coming in
across more eastern and central areas
tomorrow as that wind turns more
northeasterly that will bring in a bit
more cloud as well but otherwise it's
just beautiful out there there's lots of
sunshine there is a fair amount of cloud
across southern scotland northern
england and the east coast of scotland
but i think that'll break up
with sunny spells and the best of the
temperatures will be in the west
further east particularly northeast
it'll still be cool in fact a bit cooler
than yesterday at around 11 or 12
celsius
it'll be starry for most tonight so
again a touch of frost is likely
but tomorrow i think we should do quite
well there'll be a bit more cloud in the
sky i think during sunday but a pretty
decent day warmest in the west
as i hinted at earlier cooler for more
central and eastern areas
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers the broadcaster bedisha and
the comedian
mark dolan welcome back to you both
let's start with the
ft badisha and a story that we were
covering yesterday and these are the
postmasters and post mistresses that
have had their names
cleared after the most awful miscarriage
of justice
this is an absolutely extraordinary
story which seems to have come out of
nowhere but has actually been going on
really for decades now so it refers to
a group of prosecutions in the mid 2000s
which came in the wake of the post
office introducing
something as simple as a new accounting
and stock taking system called
horizon so that those went into all the
post office branches and sub branches
and they led to a few glitches and a
little bit of under reporting
now you'd think that the post office
would just turn around
look into it and go okay there's been a
mistake instead
it convicted dozens 39 have been
overturned so far 22 cases are still
ending
convicted dozens of postmasters and
post-mistresses and sub-masters
of fraud embezzlement of somehow
stealing the money themselves and this
led to dozens of actual convictions and
prison time
ranging from several months to several
years it's an absolutely extraordinary
case because you can't believe
that a trusted and actually beloved
organization
was set up like the post office could
possibly
deliberately overlook what is really a
quite a simple
um computer error it's not anybody's
fault when these things happen
and instead as neil hudgell one of the
lawyers representing dozens of victims
says prioritize reputation
and profit over the well-being of people
who
as anyone knows who goes to their local
post office branch
they're run by wonderful people they're
often family businesses they're run by
people who
have partners and children and have been
the victims of an
absolutely amazing triumph of
reputation and profit over basic common
human decency now the victims and their
families are calling for a proper
public neutral inquiry not just
government commentary which is what
we're seeing at the moment even though
the pm
is obviously behind these people who've
been exonerated
and they're also now calling for the
prosecution
of the perpetrators in this case so all
of those people
involved with the post office who knew
this was happening and didn't say
anything but we don't know what's
happening on that issue
so far yes no i think that this story uh
will will continue just that the sense
of injustice is is huge
uh mark let's move on to the story that
we've been covering our lead and the the
crisis the coveted crisis in india
and this spike where where people are
literally dying on the floor
of hospitals as your coverage
demonstrates
and as the papers are showing as well
via graphic images
such as this one in the guardian what's
emerging in india is a humanitarian
crisis it's something that we feared
here in the uk the idea
of our nhs being overwhelmed well sadly
this is what it looks like
yesterday extraordinarily india reported
over 300 000
covid cases it's a health healthcare
system that is
at um full stretch of the best of times
an enormous population
huge poverty and inequality in india and
we're seeing the consequences of that
now
and it's a timely reminder that
notwithstanding the huge success of our
vaccine roll out here in the uk
the our next focus has to be to get the
world vaccinated and to get countries
that are not in a
lucky and privileged position like us
to be protected issue to the sun
take us to this story on um tesla
the autopilot uh car
yes i mean you know the moment anyone
says the words tesla
on autopilot you know that the answer
isn't going to be good and i think this
is exactly the problem that
tesla has had that elon musk we enjoy
hearing stories about his shenanigans
and now in texas there have been two
more deaths
with two passengers that were riding in
what was a fully automated enabled
they say car there was nobody in the
driver's seat
when the car was found crashed into a
tree
we know from multiple reports really
over the last two or three years that
it's very possible
to trick the the autopilot enabled
system
into driving itself just by putting a
weight
on the steering wheel or putting a
weight or certain stress
on various sensors within the driving
compartment of the car itself now we
know also because i looked into this i
was fascinated by this story that
in private correspondence those at tesla
have actually said
that it is not possible to enter these
cars
into fully automated driver mode so even
though
that's the branding that's the story
they're putting out there you're
actually supposed to
keep pressure on the wheel every 10
seconds you're supposed to do various
things which
reassures the car that you are actually
driving it
and instead what seems to be happening
is that
tesla is using the common population of
ordinary people you me anyone using the
roads
as some sort of human test case
to see how far they can go and don't do
this but if you're a journalist
and you've ever looked into this there's
plenty of footage
of these so-called self-driving
semi-autonomous
vehicles getting involved in really very
gruesome
fatal crashes so i'm extremely
ambivalent
whenever i see tesla tesla or elon musk
in the newspapers in this way because
this is not a joke and it's not funny
and life is not a computer game and
frankly having fully automated cars on
the road is not any kind of priority
in the unequal world um that we live in
where someone like elon musk's resources
and ingenuity could be put to much
better use
yeah no it's very mark i can see you
want to come in there
well i beg to differ slightly because i
do agree that certainly we shouldn't be
human guinea pigs
and these trials have to happen in a
safe environment and badisha is
absolutely right about that
but deaths on the road injuries on the
road are an absolute tragedy and if we
get this right
a computer is far more trustworthy a
driver
than a human being oh
i think i think you've opened up a can
of worms there and we could
go on and on on that discussion but but
mark just to round us up we've got about
60 seconds to tell us about the great
white shark coming to the uk in the star
listen i always try to bring good news
stories but just as we are you know
reaching a good level in terms of the
pandemic that awful cases are coming
down and we can look forward to an
optimistic summer
there's a shark on the way she's
enormous she is called nakumi
she is 50 she's 253
stone which by the way is very slim for
a great white shark so we're not dissing
her
and she took a wrong turn she normally
heads up and down the west coast of
america
and canada but she turned left and she's
on her way to the uk at least that's
what the star will have you believe
1700 miles from the uk at the moment
which is too close
for comfort i'm one of those people that
worries about jellyfish so this is my
worst nightmare yeah
a big nightmare and for dominic cummings
who's pictured in the water with her
there on the front of the star
mark and bedisha thank you so much
you